okay so once a week or maybe once every
two weeks Papa and I decided that we
need to no matter what take a couple's
datee okay and on this couple date it
doesn't have to be crazy it doesn't have
to be fancy but we do really try to look
a little bit more presentable for
ourselves and by we I think it's more on
my end cuz it's really easy for me to
look frumpy really fast you always look
good though you always look like you're
like going to go to complex Conor agenda
or something like you always look fresh
well I love you no I love you for that
hold on hold on um so he looks really
handsome right now my papa looks very
very handsome I'm just wearing the true
you are you are but then I know the the
July bar Brigade drop yeah and you look
really good cuz you match the colors and
everything right but those shoes god
damn it those
shoes don't move I'm trying to zoom in
on them I just hate it I hate Crocs I
hate Crocs and I hate those these are so
dope I love these I know you were trying
to compliment me but what the these are
like H so they're like so I think Crocs
now they're played out everyone has them
right so I'm like okay but that style is
still in which is why everyone's
adopting them Nike got their own Crocs
every company got their own Crocs I saw
hokas I'm a big fan of Hoka cuz they're
squishy I'm heavy I got dense bones and
I saw these and I was like you know what
these kind of look like the Nike
hes and they're still breathable like
Crocs I'm going to rock these and
they're convenient to put on and off
because I'm a Believer in the Crocs now
okay when we walk we have to be this
much aart so and then let me walk a
little bit more in front of you so
people don't think we're together why
cuz I hate those well after your insult
let me compliment you no look look at
Mama's outfit Mama's outfit looks l i
mean it's you got those fly ass A6 it's
just P you got what is that MAF what
what color pants are those M lavender or
something and it and you got the barbell
shirt on yeah but you see this and then
it matches with the hat yeah cuz it's
the B so I was like oh see socks to make
the black hair pop to give it cuz if it
was white then you kind of just look
like a mom yeah but you need a little
bit I don't know I probably still just
look like a mom let's just go let's go
be a
couple all right for today's little Vlog
date we're going to this place called
laay laayi so I follow a bunch of uh
Vegas food spots and this looks crazy
bomb it's like egg noodles with like a
Thai curry and like crunchy noodles look
at that and that stewed beef or meat oh
[__] good that looks good huh yeah so um
since we've moved to Vegas besides like
the regular food spots we have on
circulation we actually haven't tried
that much and we've been here for almost
3 years now almost two right one two no
T well Tao did preschool kindergarten
from first grade so like two and a half
so and half of the reason why is because
I've always been on a diet you know
bodybuilding get Lan and I lost like 50
lbs the the other is me and M bear we
get so busy that we kind of get in the
same routine so whatever is easy and
convenient that's what we go with and
plus as you guys know taica gets
seizures so we have to end our day at
7:30 so that we can get taica in bed by
8 because sleep is the number one or
lack of sleep is the number one cause of
seizures so because for him so because
of that we have to crunch so much into
the day we got to take them to Jiu-Jitsu
swimming basketball whatever and then so
a lot of times for dinner we don't even
get to eat out as much which is why we
wanted to make this lunch date thing a
thing and because we've been so busy
we've also been slacking off on the
Vlogs I know I know I know a lot of you
guys enjoy seeing our interaction us and
ta's interaction the dogs the updates on
the homes shout outs to all of you guys
that's so cool cuz we like sharing that
stuff too so this will be an effort to
do all the above try lots of yummy eats
cuz I'm no longer on a diet but don't
worry fat B is not coming back you know
that's one of the comments people will
be like oh I like fat bar I want fat bar
to come back no we don't we don't want
fat bar to come back I was looking over
some old footage like our uh honeymoon
feel bad for me I do actually cuz uh I
looked at the the footage of us going to
uh Europe and you look so beautiful and
exquisite and like you look so lean
andery have a nice you trying to have a
nice day I'm trying to I'm working on my
dessert right now on the dessert menu
you know what I'm saying oh I mean it's
looking really good for you and then I
looked at myself and I was like holy
[__] I must have been like 220 in Paris
always you're always
220 it's crazy how many times I've
competed at 181 though and you know what
sucks is whenever I've been big when I
was pregnant and like I couldn't really
enjoy it that's when you were really
lean and I'm like why would you do that
to
me but guess what I'm back to lanart I
love it we're in the now I'm keeping it
this way love it and I'm a balance it
out with every every week or every other
week when we eat out a couple times all
the other ones shout outs to Trifecta
always hooks me up with the meals I try
to eat clean but today is a day of
indulgence because I've been eating
clean for 3 days straight and uh I can't
wait to try more Vegas food with y'all
all right so I got high hopes for this
place because we just exited and we're
rarely on this side of the town where
the strip is oh yeah but we're about to
enter into the heart of Chinatown AKA
Spring
Mountain and usually all the Asian spots
in Spring Mountain are banging and you
know that it's really good when so I
just clicked on their Instagram and they
have two locations so that usually means
like one of the location killed it
already and they open a second one so
they got one in Chinatown Vegas and the
other one in Henderson laay laayi but
all the food looks good oh babe if they
have um mango sticky rice but we're
doing it we have to do it cuz I love
mango sticky rice you love mango yeah I
love mango it always surprises me how
much you love mango and I don't know why
it surprises me like it's not a Mango's
delicious it shouldn't be a surprise
right but like that being your favorite
fruit is that's not my favorite fuit you
know what my favorite fruit
is I think my hands down alltime
favorite food when I'm a kid till now
has to be fruit has to be I think
peaches that's I wanted a peach tree in
our backyard you never eat peaches I
know never we there every time we go get
groceries you're getting pineapple
grapes cuz it's already peeled it's easy
I'm lazy too don't peaches you just eat
it what are you talking about that's
true I'll get more peaches next time and
oranges oranges you have to peel dude
you peel
it no I don't or Tanger like you get
everything but what you love like I love
oranges oranges are my [__] right like I
love oranges then second is guava always
vas are it guavas but we just don't get
a lot of them out here or anywhere
really um unless I'm like in Hawaii or
whatever but Taiwan some tropical as
Place yeah but I always get
oranges but you never Chinatown
Chinatown looks yeah [__]
me [__] you why oh cuz I was still
talking but yeah no it is tight like I
don't like this is sick we don't have
Mexicans don't have anything like this
yeah you guys just have
graffiti yeah cuz the Chinese people are
doing it what's up with that
what do you mean Chinese people are
doing it yeah all the Asians are doing
it doing graffiti yeah why they why they
do that what oh there's a c here
too dude we got to eat there revolving
Su dude let's do it dude I can tell I
could tell this date's going really good
to I think she's going to put out guys
all right so we're about to enter into
this parking lot it's next to Sparrow
and wolf which I've heard good things
about never tried it next the taru sushi
is laay or you said it's llama the
second llama the second cuz this is the
second
location okay oh yeah other one's llama
the first yeah dude it went over your
head and you caught it real quick but
it's okay moving on no cuz I got caught
up in the sign it said it was a winery
too I was like what like or it says a
modern eery wine and Cocktails I was
like
what oh this restaurant's
pretty look at
that some of it is
good
this restaurant's pretty
mama this is fany fany look at the
utensils it's the golden one
ooh all right since I'm the [__] man
here I'm going to grab this chick by the
neck and I'm just going to order yes
what else you doing I'm going grab her
by the [__] neck and I'm going to
tell her what she's going to eat okay
just just putting on my my Andrew Tate
hat okay no no no no let not take that
[__] off that guy's cool I like like
them no take it off all right well
anyways we're going to get the wings up
that looks really good spicy fried
chicken wings with lime oh Thai spicy is
a different I need to tell them mild it
down cuz Tha will [__] you up I'm also
going to get the Yum nure grilled riy
steak salad that looks really good oh
even has a star next to it which
means oh it's just consuming ramies okay
yeah I'm going to get that and then I'm
and we're going to get two of those
noodles that we saw cuz they
look delicious and since I'm at a Thai
restaurant and I never get this I have
to get a Thai iced tea cuz it's just
traditional are you ready to order yes
I'm ready to order thank
you did you just make a big mess already
I knew you were going to call me out you
son of a [__] no I'm
not cut it I'm just kidding don't cut
it Dam this color is nice damn this is
good it's good huh you know what other
thing I also like about this restaurant
they give you do the water cuz like I
hate it when like you need to drink
water and you have to keep Korean
barbecue yeah and it's like they only
give you like only a little bit and it's
like you go through this so fast you
want just take this honestly for
American each we need to have two of
these one per person I don't know if we
drink enough water I usually do but
since we're drinking a noodle soup I
won't but I usually can drink like a
whole thing of water yeah you're pretty
thirsty you're thirsty M all right so I
was on the Yelp and I saw a picture of
the Wings and it look bomb and I love uh
fried wings with a dry rub on it and
this one has like a chili lime dry rub
so please do the honors and tell me how
it tastes it smells amazing does it like
you know um so it smells a little bit
like chicken but it smells like sweet
like a sweet deep fried ice cream type
of batter don't even smell that my
stuffy ass smells
see oh it feels really hot you really
want me to eat this yeah it's a little
nibble on it oh what the I know what a
graceful date you are oh man it smells
juicy
too
M it's really good that's really yummy
would you recommend it to tell someone
else to get it I would I would do your
best Keith Lee impression who Keith Lee
who's that the guy that rates all the
food I will not no he's beloved put your
hands together like this where all five
fingers touch each other okay
I'll even do the edits zoom zoom zoom
like this close
wow that's too much
emotion that
hits that's
not who are you watching I don't know I
told you I didn't want to you pressured
me and I just I crack Under
Pressure okay talking so much [__] you
do it he starts like
this
I will rate I will rate this food on a
scale of 1 through five that's really
good he goes like that goes one for
cleanliness the service the service was
immaculate yeah I sucked yours is really
good so are you a wing person or I love
wing or a drumstick person oh drumstick
cuz it's more meat I like drumstick but
for me to accurately rate a wing place I
feel like I got to eat the wings no [__]
cuz it's a wing place but they got drums
in the wings okay
go M that's a
good M that's a flaky
batter o and the lime is all the way on
the inside of the meat too
yummy that is
flaky it's almost like fish and chips
flaky it is it is that's what reminded
me of to the batter it's light it
doesn't feel very oily yummy yum
yum
so this dish just entered the chat what
is that it's grilled riye it's a salad
but I don't give a [__] about the
veggies I only saw pictures of the meat
so I'm going ignore like the salad even
exists and I'm going to go just based
off the meat Savage you going to try it
yes yes I'm going use my fingers because
that's how you're supposed to it's okay
I love
you love that Medium
rareness take off all those weird
greens
M I do love the liness of Tai food I do
unmatched
Immaculate I'll scale of 1 through 10
the liness was a nine I would give 10
but there's always room for
improvement was it good though it was
really good okay damn I didn't even get
to cut it and this came in what is that
all right so this is what we came here
for the kasoy I believe is how you
pronounce it and the food comes out fast
here so I love that already I hate it
when the food takes forever but this is
what we came here for with the egg
noodles and everything exactly what I
saw on the um the Instagrams oh
Instagram oh it's a good curly smells
good and I love egg noodles and I make a
mess so I have to eat like this I don't
think anyone's questioning that we get
it oo look at that look at these egg
noodles oh I love egg noodles so
much M really yeah it's a good curry
it's like deep if it was raining or if I
just came off of sickness this would be
so perfect yeah is it limey at all a
little bit but it's just like a good
tight no just a just a little bit of
not really
spicy soft Ste meat
TR here we go here we go here we
go D you put the Hat up too huh come to
you look like a train
conductor
M I see what you mean it tastes very
homey too right it tastes really homey
like like if you told your mom you were
sick and she was like don't worry I got
just the
theme [__] bada beam bada boom [__]
riy Wing zap
costy it's good did I pick a good place
mhm you pick the next one okay good Lu
what the [__] this is
beautiful so what do we get is that ice
cream yep o la Zam zaddy and then we got
some bananas you definitely got the
[__] eyes for dessert man but I do
like me some deep fried bananas and I'm
stoked to they got freaking flour on
there yeah yeah that's what I I've had
this before but uh-huh what is it
called pona or something like that is it
good
look at all the
details I don't know this is TI but I'm
a big fan of brick toast what are you
saying you know it's Chinese it is taies
to be
specific TR I know you're
cating oh look at
that there probably like all kinds of
Honey action ooh oh that texture oh
damn you don't look at me like
that a little bit of this get a little
bit of this little bit of that a little
bit of
that the best
one try it later I like this flavor too
much I'm too
you don't want to clean cleanse your
pallet I like pallets that are
mixed there's no tet on the
bottom that one's good too
nice so mama how was the cyi lunch date
on a scale of 1 through 10 it was uh so
the lunch date itself was a 10 it was
was really nice um like getting to
connect with you and like putting our
phones away and not looking at any of it
and like having extreme eye contact and
being totally engaged with extreme eye
contact yeah like our our eyeballs were
touching each other we were just so
connected that's how you get pink eye no
it's when you scratch your butt and then
you scratch your eye that's pink eye
true and ta is absolutely mortified to
ever get it again every time he's like
is this clean mom before he rubs his eye
cute is this clean like if he's going to
do this is your shirt clean
Mom I'm like yeah it's clean why he goes
and then he'll like rub his face but
like everything is it clean a Cy guy um
but yeah it was a ton it was really Cy
and then the food was really good like I
don't normally crave Thai food maybe
because I just haven't had really good
Thai food yeah um and I guess in
California the really good or La the
good Thai food is in Hollywood yep and I
don't really go out that way very much
cuz it's just [__] blocked and
congested everywhere um so yeah this bot
was really good and it's not just your
typical dishes hell yeah good job give
me your best Donald Trump impression no
come on tell me how good the food is in
I don't know say say the no I don't know
I say you you you want to eat you like
the fried chicken and it with Donald
Trump tell no I don't know how you just
try just try it I can't even hear his
voice in my head yeah you
can your face just try just try
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh all right before I end this Cy date
Vlog I want to show you guys how I'm
able to maintain balance how I'm able to
just eat what I just ate and still be
able to maintain a 133% body fat which
is pretty close to 10 after the
bodybuilding show and it's been a few
months now so first of all thank you and
big shout outs to Trifecta they're the
ones that keep me hooked up um I balance
all my days out with about 3 days of
clean eating and then I'll have one meal
not one full day but one meal of cheat
meals and that allows me to still be
able to enjoy life enjoy Vegas travel
and indulge in some of the yummier
things in life but also allow me to stay
lean and keep my weight under control so
what I'm going to be packing is my next
set of meal preps so I'll be eating
something just simple there two patties
with some rice I put in tupperware put
it away cuz I'm one of those guys that
if I don't have food around that's when
I'm in trouble cuz then that's when my
wheels start turning and I go M should I
get in and out or should I get some
Popeye's fried chicken and that's when I
get in big trouble but when I have food
ready to go then as soon as I'm hungry
I'm like boom what's more convenient
than having Tupperware right there toss
in the microwave not to mention all of
the meat from Trifecta comes from
organic sources so it's one of the
highest quality of proteins that you can
eat anyways and I like to vary my
protein sources so I eat beef and
chicken all the time which is why I get
their bison burger super lean very very
flavorful literally tastes just like
beef except it's leaner but um juicier
so this should be able to make me a good
four meals and I'll show you what it
looks like when it's done I can just
pack it and if I need to go la go
wherever I need to travel easy peasy and
Bam in under 2 minutes I've prepped my
next four meals and each one of these
bad boys is about
520 calories cuz I'm doing double Patty
for each so I believe the macros are 60
protein 20 fat so it's 3:1 ratio and
then about 30 G of carbs so amounts to
about
520 calories so each day I could
technically have two of these I'll be at
120 down a protein shake already at 170
and have like a little snack and I'll be
under way under 2,000 calories and so
still be able to hit my protein goals
get a big squat big bench um and still
stay relatively lean and also not to
mention save time cuz one of my favorite
things about Trifecta is all the food
comes pre-cooked so you just have to
throw it in the microwave and save money
because we all know when we go out you
indulge as you guys saw like sometimes
I'll get two drinks I got got to get two
desserts cuz I'm split down the middle
like today's bill came out to like
1225 and when I order stuff like that
like off the trifecta site 125 will
literally get me almost 10 meals you
know but that was just one so shout outs
to Trifecta um if you want to give them
a try go to the website don't forget to
use code Bart 40 for 40% off your first
order thank you to Trifecta and thank
you for watching this Q date Vlog if you
want to see more date Vlogs and if
there's any places you recommend in
Vegas let us know we'll go check that
out see you guys next time peace